تركيا تنهي عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
المناطق المنكوبه الجيش الامريكي لا
يستبعد تعرض بلاده لهجمات من الفضاء
مفاجاه حول مومياء حوريه البحر في اليابان
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من تركيا حيث اعلنت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ انهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
معظم المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب البلاد في السادس من الشهر
الجاري وفيما تشهد تركيا حاليا عمليات
للتثبت من الجثث المجهوله عبر فحص الحمض
النووي دعى وزير الداخليه تركي المواطنين
للتوجه الى مراكز مخصصه في كل ولايه
للحصول على عينه دم لاجراء الفحص وتسهيل
التعرف على اصحاب الجثث مجهوله الهويه
موجها اصابع الاتهام الى روسيا والصين اكد
قائد عمليات الفضاء في الجيش الامريكي
الجنرال جون ريموند امكانيه تعرض الولايات
المتحده لهجمات من الفضاء رايموند اعتبر
ان المنافسه في الفضاء تغيرت بشكل الجوهري
مع الصين وروسيا مؤكدا ان هذين البلدين
ينتجان اسلحه فضائيه تشكل تهديدا على
بلاده وان الصين تحديدا تعد التهديد
الاكبر للولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق
بالهجمات من الفضاء
حقيقه صادمه ظهرت اخيرا وراء مومياء حوريه
البحر التي انتشلت قبل الثلاثمائه عام على
السواحل اليابانيه في المحيط الهادئ
وقدسها بعض اليابانيين بزعم ان قوتها تمنح
الخلود خصوص متنوعه بالاشعه السينيه
والمسح المقطعي وغيرهما اجرته اجرتها
جامعه كوره شيكي للعلوم والفنون اثبتت ان
المومياء المزعومه مصنعه يدويا وان الجزء
العلوي منها يتكون من القماش والورق
والقطن غير ان استخدام بعض المواد الحيويه
من الاسماك والحيوانات اثار اللغط حوله
هويه المومياء لفتره طويله من الزمن
في حادث جديد يثير مزيدا من الشكوك اعلنت
ادارته الاطفاء في ولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه ان سائق سياره تسلا لقيا حتفه
اثر اصطدامه بشاحنه اطفاء على طريق سريعه
الحادث ياتي في وقت تحقق فيه الجهات
التنظيميه في الولايات المتحده بشان
سيارات تسلا المزوده بنظام القياده الاليه
لمساعده السائق وذلك بعد سلسله من الحوادث
كان بعضها مميتا فيما اعلنت تسلا استدعاء
اكثر من 360 الف سياره في امريكا لتحديث
برنامج القياده الذاتيه الكامله
بسبب سلوك غريب لاحظوه عليه قبيل وقوع
الزلزال تمكنت اسره تركيه في ولايه
عثمانيه من النجاه من عواقب الكارثه
المدمره التي ضربت البلاد بفضل ببغاء
ترعاه في منزلها وسائل الاعلام محليه قالت
ان افراد العائله تجاوبوا مع اصوات غير
عاديه اصدرها الببغاء قبل وقوع الزلزال
بلحظات الامر الذي حفزهم على الفور الى
مغادره المنزل والنجاه بحياتهم في وقت
اشار فيه كثير من الخبراء الى ان
الحيوانات تستطيع فعلا استشعار الزلازل
وغيرها من الكوارث الطبيعيه قبل وقوعها